[Musique]
bonjour yves d'amécourt merci beaucoup
d'être en direct ce matin avec nous sur
rt france réaction alors emmanuel macron
aurait tranché et ce serait oui pour la
tenue des élections régionales et
départementales en juin
votre réaction oui ma réaction d'abord
c'est que il ya encore le débat à
l'assemblée nationale
aujourd'hui on va voir un petit peu
comment nos députés imagine des choses
parce que une élection ce n'est pas
juste le jour du scrutin c'est aussi une
campagne électorale
je vous rappelle qu'aujourd'hui les
français n'ont pas le droit de se
déplacer à plus de dix kilomètres de
leur domicile et donc nous nous sommes
en campagne dans la région nouvelle
aquitaine elle compte six millions
d'habitants et elle va de des pyrénées
jusqu'à la creuse au plateau des
millevaches et donc moi je serais très
intéressé de savoir comment ce que le
gouvernement je vois l'organisation de
cette campagne électorale dans les
débats qui vont avoir lieu aujourd'hui à
l'assemblée nationale et vous la voyez
comment vous concrètement concrètement
si le gouvernement ne met en place un
système de campagne sans contact
c'est-à-dire en réservant des créneaux
sur le service public de l'information
notamment le réseau france 3 pour que
les candidats puissent s'exprimer en
réservant des créneaux sur le réseau de
radio france et notamment le réseau
france bleu pour que les candidats
puissent débattre en donnant des en
achetant des ddd pages dans les journaux
de la presse quotidienne régionale ou de
là où delà de la presse hebdomadaire
local pour que les candidats puissent
s'exprimer devant les électeurs parce
que une campagne sans contact ça va ça
s'organise et aujourd'hui rien n'est
prévu il est dommage que le gouvernement
n'est pas non plus prévu une application
pour pouvoir voter sans contact
notamment pour les plus jeunes d'entre
nous fait rien n'a été prévu tout ça est
dans l'improvisation totale on a
l'impression que le gouvernement avait
vraiment l'intention de de repousser ce
scrutin sans vraiment s'organiser pour
le faire alors ils avaient l'intention
de le repousser ce que ce scrutin
on va écouter justement une lettre qui
avait été envoyé hier par territoire
unis qui regroupe la mmf et
df justement regarder le président de la
république a annoncé un calendrier de
réouverture du pays dès le début du mois
de mai et on pourrait pas aller voter en
juin le gouvernement n'a donc à ce point
pas confiance dans sa stratégie
vaccinale
en réalité le gouvernement n'a peur ni
de l'épidémie ni de la capacité des
mères ce dont il a peur c'est du verdict
des urnes
est-ce que selon vous le gouvernement
avait peur du verdict des urnes on sait
que l'ancrage local et pas vraiment
satisfaisant pour la république en
marche
le gouvernement n'a pas vraiment peur du
verdict des urnes pour la république en
marche qui était imparti finalement sans
élu est aujourd'hui quasiment 100
militants il avait surtout peur du score
des candidats aux régionales qui
envisage de se présenter à l'élection
présidentielle en concurrence avec le
président emmanuel macron et donc c'est
xavier bertrand c'est laurent wauquiez
c'est valérie pécresse qui sont des des
présidents de région qui aujourd'hui
sont donné gagnant dans les sondages
même si les sondages ne valent pas
scrutin et donc je pense que le
président emmanuel macron ne voulait pas
que les élections régionales servent de
de prélude à la campagne présidentielle
mais il s'en était exprimé d'ailleurs
ouvertement au président de région
puisque au moment il ya un an au moment
de la deûle entrée dans le confinement
il avait dit aux régions les le
gouvernement vous aidera à condition que
vous acceptiez de déplacer les élections
régionales donc on était dans un espèce
de bras de fer il d'amécourt là
l'argument de dire que fillon on a deux
un début de retour à la normale on mais
c'est vrai qu'il n'y a pas de raison de
ne pas pouvoir se déplacer faire
campagne du sciage en ont oui enfin une
campagne régionale vous savez la
nouvelle aquitaine la région sur lequel
nous sommes élus ses six millions
d'habitants et ses grands comme
l'autriche donc une campagne électorale
ne s'improvise pas en quelques semaines
il faut vraiment que l'on puisse avoir
contact avec l'électorat le risque que
l'on a aujourd'hui c'est qu' il y ait
une abstention très forte pour ces
élections régionales que les gens ne
soient pas mobilisés comme ça a été le
cas aux municipales avec le le gloubi
boulga de décision et de non décision du
gouvernement est donc voilà on abîme
encore un petit peu plus aujourd'hui le
suffrage universel qui est un outil très
important de
l'organisation de notre démocratie
scientifique ont pas voulu vraiment se
prononcer sur la tenue de ces élections
ils ont laissée à l'exécutif le choix de
se prononcer des élections qui
pourraient avoir lieu en extérieur avec
contraintes de vaccination pour ceux qui
seraient dans les bureaux de vote ça
vous convient en fait si vous voulez le
ce week end le gouvernement a envoyé un
questionnaire à tous les élus en leur
envoyant les contraintes qu'impose elle
conseil scientifique l'objectif c'était
de faire peur aux élus pour qu'ils
répondent oui au report
et puis c'était aussi l'objectif de 2 de
transférer la patate chaude et de dire
mais finalement si vous répondez oui
vous serez responsable de l'organisation
du scrutin que savoir que la mer il est
à la fois représentant des habitants de
sa population mais il est aussi le
représentant de l'état sur sa commune et
donc en consultant les maires finalement
le gouvernement a joué son rôle de
consultation de son représentant sur la
commune ça va pas être simple organiser
surtout qui a deux votes le même jour
c'est à dire que les bureaux de vote
vont être doublées et que le conseil
scientifique impose que les scrutateurs
soit soient vaccinés donc bon courage à
mes à mes collègues et amis maires pour
organiser ce scrutin le scrutin en
extérieur va écouter il faudrait que le
gouvernement ne décide parce
qu'aujourd'hui les bureaux de vote
ils sont définis par arrêté préfectoral
et donc si le scrutin doit avoir lieu en
extérieur mais il faut que le préfet
prenne ses responsabilités échanges
l'adresse des bureaux de vote pour les
installer sur les places des villages
voilà en espérant qu'il fera beau ce
jour là c'est ce que j'allais dire et
peut-être avec des tentes à la
disposition des électeurs vous parler
d'être la vaccination
caen était dans votre région on a vu que
le gouvernement s'était félicité d'avoir
vacciné 10 millions de français ce
week-end vous ça vous satisfait écoutez
c'est toujours un petit peu la bérézina
parce que il ya encore des gens qui sont
dans les populations à risques qui ne
sont pas vaccinés
j'ai une amie l'autre jour qui habite en
gironde qui est allé se faire vacciner à
angoulême parce qu'elle trouvait pas de
place en gironde
tout ça est à l'avenant et
malheureusement moi je souffre beaucoup
depuis un an de voir que la france qui
était quand même
un pays où on savait organiser les
choses ou la logistique n'était pas un
problème on disait des joueurs
d'ailleurs toujours décidons la
logistique suivra et en ce moment on
s'aperçoit que 1 on ne décide pas et que
de la logistique ne suit pas
heureusement qu'il ya des mères comme le
maire de de cannes par exemple où le les
élus de corse du sud pour nous montrer
qu'il est un chemin pour arriver à
vacciner mais ce chemin n'est pas
emprunter malheureusement par par le
gouvernement français vous parlez des
élections présidentielles tout à l'heure
je voudrais qu'on écoute à présent ce
qu'a dit philippe de villiers le
fondateur du puy du fou n'a pas mâché
ses mots pour lui ce sera compliqué pour
le président de se représenter regardez
j'ai du mal à penser qu emmanuel macron
puissent se représenter il a enfermé les
français quand votre nom est associé à
un malheur vous partez avec le malheur
il a même cité churchill ou clemenceau
est ce qu il a raison
selon vous je pense qu'il a raison pour
deux raisons d'abord parce que le péché
originel des manuels macron c'est
d'avoir convaincu françois hollande de
ne pas se présente de ne pas se
représenter je pense que il lui arrivera
à lui la même chose parce que c'est le
président finalement de l'enfermement
c'est le président du coronavirus c'est
le président de tous les ratages que
nous vivons depuis un an sur sur cette
pandémie
le ratage des des masques le ratage des
vaccins le ratage des tests et des
autotests aujourd'hui et donc on a
besoin d'un chef et vraisemblablement
emmanuel macron a beaucoup de qualités
il s'exprime bien c'est un homme de
théâtre c'est un homme de culture mais
ce n'est pas le chef dont la france a
besoin
qu'en est il des variants on sait que le
varions brésilien inquiète beaucoup les
scientifiques on voit que la france a
maintenu ses vols en provenance du
brésil alors que d'autres pays
les ondes interdite faudrait-il à
interrompre ses vols selon vous en
provenance du brésil à l'heure actuelle
en fait c'est assez incroyable que la
france est en train de supprimer des
vols intérieurs et elle laisse
fonctionner des vols extérieur et le
ministre djebbari nous explique qu'il
n'a pas le choix que c'est
des règles internationales qu'on n'a pas
le droit d'arrêter des vols enfin tout
ça est incroyable il faut prendre ses
responsabilités et donc si on doit pour
des raisons sanitaires surtout qui a pas
de quarantaine imposée à ses passagers
en provenance du brésil alors que c'est
le cas non mais vous vous rendez compte
on impose des quarantaines au sein même
de l'europe et on est incapable
d'imposer des quarantaines avec le
brésil alors c'est pas la peine sur les
estrades d'aller dire le plus grand mal
du président ball sonar ou quand il ya
un incendie dans la forêt amazonienne et
ne pas prendre ses responsabilités quand
on est sur une crise sanitaire avec un
variant identifié et dangereux donc on
ne comprend pas la façon d'agir de ce
gouvernement
quant au ministre des transports je
crois que dans l'histoire de la vème
république c'est la première fois qu'on
a un ministre des transports qui passe
son temps à en supprimer
finalement il supprime des transports
plus qu'il n'en crée une encre est pas
le président de la région
auvergne rhône-alpes laurent wauquiez
s'est insurgé contre l'ouverture d'une
école musulmane financé par un groupe
proche de la turquie
voyez ce qu'il en a dit et on en parle
après l'école serait un établissement
hors contrat dont l'orientation
consistera très clairement à promouvoir
des valeurs qui ne sont pas celles
aujourd'hui de la république
est ce que c'est une menace pour la
laïcité cette école hors contrat qui
serait financé partiellement par une
organisation islamiste qui s'appelle
milly gourou ce qui est proche de la
turquie la loi séparatisme a été durci à
en première lecture au sénat hier soir
et elles visent notamment à empêcher ce
genre de choses alors à quoi ça sert
d'avoir une loi quand on voit que ce
genre de chose est possible
en fait dans ce dossier il ya deux
dossiers le premier dossier c'est
l'achat d'un immeuble dans la ville
d'albertville parmi les goûts russe est
donc aujourd'hui laurent wauquiez est a
raison de dire et le maire d'albertville
a raison de dire que nous n'avons pas
les moyens d'empêcher une association
quelle qu'elle soit d'acheter un
immeuble dans une ville voilà et de
déposer un permis de construire pour
transformer cet immeuble en longueur en
l'occurrence c'est un changement de
destination donc transformé un immeuble
d'habitation en école donc ça c'est le
premier dossier est donc si le
gouvernement veut changer ces choses là
bas il faut changer la loi
parce que en fait le maire il agit au
nom du préfet et que le préfet même si
il n'est pas de cet avis la loi
s'applique donc la loi on la change pas
en fonction de qui achète un immeuble
et puis ensuite il ya le deuxième sujet
qui est l'ouverture de l'école au sein
de l'immeuble est donc là bas il ya une
loi sur l'ouverture des écoles hors
contrat et avec la particularité que
cette association milite au russe je
vous rappelle que c'est celle qui veut
construire une mosquée à strasbourg n'a
pas signé la charte de l'islam en france
qu'à demander de signer le gouvernement
est donc là il ya il ya un autre souci
et on est en plein débat au parlement
sur ce sujet là et donc c'est le moment
de créer de faire des amendements dans
cette loi pour pour ça pour s'adapter à
cette situation
des situations qui va se répéter dans
les mois et les années qui viennent
puisque le président erdogan
a demandé aux turcs de rester turc de
garder leur civilisation turque où
qu'ils soient et il veut former des
petites turque dans tous les pays du
monde
alors justement le sénat a voté un
amendement justement qui doit permettre
aux pressé de s'opposer à l'ouverture de
ce genre d'école qui serait soutenu par
un état je cite hostile à la république
cet amendement va dans le bon sens la
droite a bien fait de durcir cette cette
loi sur le séparatisme selon vous elle
fait bien de le durcir il faut faire
juste attention de pas se servir d'un
cas particulier pour pour voter une loi
générale pour pas que ça retombe après
ça sur d'autres associations qui ne pose
aucun problème
milli gorus n'est pas vraiment le bras
mais non plus d'erdogan puisque ces îles
sont pas forcément en odeur de sainteté
si je puis me permettre cette expression
avec le président turc
mais il faut veiller surtout à ce que le
président turc qui se rêve en calife à
la place du calife ne puisse pas arriver
à ses fins et que l'on maintienne
surtout le socle de nos valeurs et la
civilisation nationale en empêchant que
des petits français soient formés dans
un autre socle les systèmes de valeur
que celui de la nation qui s'appuie sur
la liberté l'égalité la fraternité la
laïcité
une dernière question des policiers ont
été caillassés à étampes ce week-end
dans l'essonne lors d'un contrôle pour
le vol d'une moto écouter ce qu'on a dit
marine le pen
tous les jours nous assistons à ces
caillassage de policiers prise à partie
par des bandes de voyous on ne peut plus
accepter la dérive accélérée de notre
pays vers l'ensauvagement et là des
civilisations il est temps de remettre
la france aux ordres ont nuit tendue à
grigny également ce week-end est ce
qu'il faut s'habituer à ce genre d'image
sans vous il faut pas s'habituer
il faut surtout pas s'habituer on en
voit souvent oui mais je pense qu'il
faut écouter aussi les spécialistes
notamment le général soubelet ancien
patron la gendarmerie qui propose que
dans ces villes particulière on est une
organisation particulière notamment
faisant appel à l'armée
en mettant ces communes sous tutelle en
en levant au maire leurs compétences de
sécurité pour la confier à l'état et
donc il faut frapper un grand coup il
faut s'organiser
donc il ne faut surtout pas s'habituer à
ça il faut surtout pas que ça devienne
une ritournelle et que finalement on
s'habitue il faut pas s'habituer
ce qui se passe là est scandaleux et
donc l'état doit prendre ses
responsabilités et le président de la
république le premier ministre le
ministre de l'intérieur doivent passer
des mots aux actes
la réponse peut se retrouver dans le
bureau de la sécurité qui est en
consultation autrement selon vous la
réponse elle se trouve dans les actes
vous savez les les les symposiums les
réunions les commissions tout ça c'est
pour retarder les décisions et donc
aujourd'hui l'arsenal juridique français
permet au ministre de l'intérieur permet
au préfet prenne au président la
république au préjudice de prendre des
décisions et d'y aller voilà on n'a pas
le droit de 2,2 caillassé des policiers
en france on n'a pas le droit de casser
des élus de la république et donc
derrière faut pas nous faire croire
qu'on n'a pas les moyens d'identifier
les auteurs de de cette triste épisode
et puis de les punir voilà par contre il
faut recruter des juges parce qu'on n'a
pas assez de juges pour juger ces gens
et pour leur faire exécuter les peines
et donc la france a besoin de dix mille
magistrat et ça c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut faire rapidement
merci beaucoup aidé à mes cours d'avoir
répondu ce matin en direct à nos
questions sur rt france